it's one of the most profitable beverage
beverage companies in the world with the
top selling beer but all we need is a
couple a couple a double digit
percentage Point drop to where
Anheuser-Busch says clearly the story
won't go away and we've seen a whole
bunch of stories over the past few years
when people get obsessed with something
and refuse to let go and you're
wondering how is this story still going
viral how are they still talking about
it because we're going to keep doing it
because the people care about it because
the commentators make money from doing
it because the Tabloid media makes money
from doing it and the only way out for
Anheuser-Busch is an apology I think the
Daily Mail had a better uh more accurate
title for this particular story they had
rules for thee not for me Bud Light exec
demanding beer update it's Friday image
is seen partying at a 2006 Harvard Booze
Fest and pounding shots from condoms so
uh yes that happened and that's what
everyone's talking about